[Applaus]
[Musik]
alle reden zurzeit vom corona virus
cupid 19 es ist wohl das thema des
jahres daher mussten auch wir ganz
schnell auf diesen zug aufspringen und
einen corona virus video drehen denn es
wurde zwar schon alles gesagt aber auch
noch nicht von jedem
ok keine angst ihr wisst dass euch hier
auf die realpolitik keine kurzlebige
news verschwörungstheorien oder
spekulationen erwarten wir schlachten
aktuelle themen nicht einfach nur für
ein paar schnelle klicks aus stattdessen
greifen wir aktuelle themen auch um
hintergründe zu beleuchten und euch über
jene zusammenhänge aufzuklären
deren wert ihr noch lange zeit nachdem
ein hype abgeklungen ist schätzen werden
[Musik]
und auch heute wollen wir euch wichtige
zusammenhänge und die folgen dieser
krise erklären die auch noch lange nach
dem abklingen der letzten corona
infektions fortbestand haben und das
leben der menschen prägen werden denn
die aktuelle entwicklung in sachen
corona ist sowieso hoch dynamisch und
alle auswirkungen noch nicht abzusehen
anstatt daher wild herum zu spekulieren
wollen wir uns lieber einer sehr
wichtigen sache annehmen die ganz
handfest nachzuvollziehen ist im
augenblick jedoch leider kaum beachtung
findet ihr könnt durchaus gespannt sein
denn wir werden euch jede mechanismen
der macht vorstellen die im rahmen einer
solchen katastrophe ihre wirkung
entfalten
[Musik]
bevor möchten wir euch jedoch kurz
bitten im fall dass ihr durch dieses
video etwas neues erfahren konnte test
auch zu liken oder über facebook und
twitter mit euren freunden zu teilen
oder wollt ihr in diesem etwa einer
neuen erkenntnisse vorenthalten
falls ihr bereits zuschauer unseres
kanals seid werdet ihr euch erinnern
dass wir euch im letzten video davon
erzählt haben wie china bereits über
viele jahre hinweg die angaben über
seine wirtschaft manipuliert und wie
auch viele andere betrügereien chinas im
finanzsektor ans tageslicht gekommen
sind
falls ihr das video noch nicht gesehen
habt könnt ihr es hier oder in der
beschreibung unter dem video anklicken
und das heißt ja keine videos mehr von
uns zu verpassen wollt aber nicht diesen
kanal und drückt auch auf die klingel um
rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden
gut also in einem video haben wir
stichhaltige beweise dafür geliefert
dass in china betrug auf allerhöchster
ebene gang und gäbe ist und wir haben
die dahinter verborgenen mechanismen der
macht in chinas politischen system
aufgedeckt ja und ganz zufällig befindet
sich das epizentrum der korona wir ihn
ja auch in china
[Musik]
in diesem video wird es uns also gar
nicht so sehr um die gesundheitlichen
folgen der epidemie gehen sondern um die
politischen und gesellschaftlichen
darüber wie skrupellos und raffiniert
die chinesische regierung diese krise
für ihre zwecke ausnutzt schauen wir uns
zunächst mal den kontext an in dem wir
uns befinden
das chinesische corona virus beliebt die
ängste in der weltwirtschaft new york
times
alibaba warnt vor schweren auswirkungen
des virus auf chinesische wirtschaft
blumer chinesische fabriken lau die us
business group mit schwerem
arbeitskräftemangel konfrontiert fonds
aktien fallen um sichere anlagen steigen
wegen der angst vor dem corona virus die
lagerbestände sinken da die angst vor
den coronado es immer größer wird
die lage ist durchaus in einer
unvergleichlichen weise dramatisch
china leidet stark unter der bedrohung
durch das corona die jungs die straßen
der städte sind praktisch leergefegt
viele fabriken einkaufszentren und
geschäfte aller art haben ihre tore
geschlossen die menschen haben angst
öffentliche verkehrsmittel zu benutzen
und einige orte wie die provinz hubei
sind gelähmt unter quarantäne gestellt
[Musik]
es ist nicht erlaubt das haus zu
verlassen und sogar mit dem auto zu
fahren
man braucht für alles eine schriftliche
genehmigung und man darf nicht einmal
mehr in die apotheke gehen oder im
supermarkt einkaufen alles zum leben
notwendige muss man sich ins haus
liefern lassen
[Applaus]
wir wollen uns aber gar nicht mal so
sehr davon ablenken lassen was die
offizielle nachrichtenagentur china ist
uns sehen lassen wollen lasst uns doch
lieber einen blick darauf werfen was sie
uns nicht sehen lassen wollen viele von
euch haben vielleicht bestimmte
einschätzungen und meinungen gehört dass
die korona virus epidemie das ende der
macht der kommunistischen partei in
china bedeuten könnte nun ganz
offensichtlich sieht dies das
kommunistische regime selbst nicht ganz
so oder sie sagen sich jedenfalls
angriff ist die beste verteidigung oder
was meint ihr ist eine solche krise
situation nicht der feuchte traum eines
jeden totalitären regimes eine situation
in der die regierung aufgrund eines
akuten notstands all ihrer maßnahmen zur
vollkommenen kontrolle der bevölkerung
ausrollen und auf äußerste verschärfen
und niemand etwas dagegen sagen denn es
geschieht ja zum schutz der bevölkerung
vor den gefährlichen virus in diesem
video beleuchten wir exemplarisch die
prinzipien dieser knallharten
machtpolitik inmitten der korona krise
und veranschaulichen sie am besten was
gerade im augenblick mit hongkong und
einem seiner schlüsselunternehmen
gesteht wir werden euch heute das
unternehmen cathay pacific vorstellen
den flag carrier also quasi die
nationale fluggesellschaft der metropole
und sonderverwaltungszone punkt
aber moment mal warum zum teufel reden
wir gerade über eine fluggesellschaft
nun heute der seichten unterhaltung
cathay pacific ist wohl das erste
beispiel dafür wie sich der
expansionismus der chinesischen
regierung nach dem ausbruch des kroner
virus dramatisch beschleunigt aber einen
schritt nach dem anderen während
unternehmen auf der ganzen welt darunter
leiden dass lieferungen von komponenten
aus china wegen fabrikschließungen und
garantien ausbleiben gilt es cathay
pacific jetzt weil man einen passagieren
es war halt sich in hongkong die zahl
der korona fälle in grenzen aber die
angst liegt in der luft und ich sage
euch die app idee hätte für diese
gesellschaft nicht zu einem schlechteren
zeitpunkt kommen können
bereits seit monaten sind die zahl der
nach hongkong kommenden touristen wegen
der proteste gegen die chinesische
regierung welche die straßen der
metropole nicht gerade attraktiv gemacht
haben bereits im jahr 2009 10 gab es in
hongkong neun millionen besucher weniger
als im feuer und mit dem koma virus
deutet alles darauf hin dass 2020 noch
schlimmer werden könnte
schaut euch mal folgendes an
[Musik]
im januar 2020 gingen die besucherzahl
in hongkong im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat um 53 prozent zurück im
januar war die angst vor dem corona
virus allerdings noch nicht so stark
verbreitet und das heißt dass die
prognosen für die nächsten monate noch
viel viel katastrophaler ausfallen
werden
was meint ihr welche arten unternehmen
leiden eurer meinung nach am meisten in
solchen krisen offensichtlich hotels und
fluggesellschaften
diese branchen sind nun mal am stärksten
von öffentlichen publikumsverkehr
abhängig und in solchen fällen daher
immer gebeutelt die politische krise in
hongkong war also bereits ein schwerer
schlag von cathay pacific was erst wird
dann das corona virus mit dem
unternehmen anrichten nun manchmal
können bestimmte einschneidende krisen
auch eine chance ein wendepunkt
darstellen denn eine notsituation kann
eine gute gelegenheit darstellen alte
zöpfe abzuschneiden sich von
verlustbringern zu befreien und neue
wege zu gehen die unter normalen
umständen schwer durchzusetzen
entscheidungen gewesen wäre
so nutzte zum beispiel die deutsche post
ag die kroger krise um die herstellung
des gefloppten elektroscooter sign zu
stellen welche der ostheide milliarde
euro verlust eingebrockt hatte aber erst
im angesicht weltweit stumpfen der
geschäfte durch corona brachte man den
mut auf das projekt einzustampfen könnte
das kronos also auch cathay pacific
letzter strohhalm sein kann die
fluggesellschaft also gerade jetzt zu
einem richtungsweisenden schlag ausholen
wie groß sind eigentlich die probleme in
denen diese firma steckt welche
maßnahmen können sie ergreifend wie
sieht die zukunft eines unternehmens aus
das seit fast einem jahr in einer
beispiellosen krise steckt 0
cathay pacific ist an ungemach gewöhnt
die letzten jahre waren volle unglücke
politische erpressungen und drohungen
[Musik]
das jahr des schreckens für cathay
pacific ist der flag carrier hongkongs
und mitunter das wichtigste unternehmen
der metropole wir sprechen hier nicht
von einer kleinen fluggesellschaft
sondern von einem der größten
luftfahrtkonzerns asiens damit ihr einen
eindruck von seiner größe bekommt cathy
verfügt derzeit über eine flotte von 152
flugzeugen allesamt großraumflugzeuge
aber das ist nur die haupt airline denn
die tochtergesellschaft cattrall welche
sich auf inlandsflüge in china
konzentriert hat weitere 48 flugzeuge
und die frachttochter hongkong
mit anderen worten wir sprechen von
einer luftfahrt gruppe mit mehr als 200
flugzeuge im einsatz und roten zu 130
ziele in der ganzen welt im vergleich
die flotte des französischen flag
carrier air france ist ähnlich groß und
zählt 225 maschinen aber frankreich hat
67 millionen einwohner hongkong nur 7,5
millionen
wenn es also cathay pacific schlecht
geht hat dies starke auswirkungen auf
ganz hongkong und umgekehrt wenn es vorn
kommen schlecht geht geht es auch
perfekt nicht gut und während dem ersten
monat des jahres 2020 die zahl der am
hamburger flughafen angekommen
passagiere im vergleich zu vorjahr um 40
prozent zurückging sanken sowohl die
zahl der passagiere als auch das
frachtvolumen kessler in den letzten
monaten unaufhörlich nur mal zur info in
der luftfahrt wird der auslastungs
faktor einer fluggesellschaft aus dem
verhältnis der von einer
fluggesellschaft angeboten sitze pro
flug kilometer zu den tatsächlich
belegten sitzen pro flugkilometer
berechnet mir klar erkennen könnt war
die zweite jahreshälfte 2009 10 für
kenner im vergleich zu 2008 10 einfach
fürchterlich und auch das frachtgeschäft
sei ganz und gar nicht rosig aus mit
anderen worten das hier ist der direkte
wirtschaftliche schaden der schwierigen
politischen situation hier ein weiteres
beispiel hongkong erlebt das erste ganze
rezessionsjahr seit einem jahrzehnt
hongkongs wirtschaft schrumpfte 2009 10
um 1,2 prozent turbulenzen im welthandel
und monatelange proteste gegen die
regierung haben die stadt ist erster
rezessionsjahr seit dem absturz während
der weltfinanzkrise im jahr 2009
getrieben wo horst return und dazu kommt
jetzt noch das krone
cathay pacific gibt gewinnwarnung heraus
kroner virus trifft das geschäft heard
the guardian mittlerweile ist der
aktienkurs von cathay pacific auf den
niedrigsten kurs seit über zehn jahren
gesucht das alles meine lieben freunde
hört sich wirklich das total an aber es
ist leider nicht die einzige und wurde
auch nicht die schlimmste bedrohung der
hongkong gegenüber steht denn womöglich
werden wir in genau diesem moment zeuge
des letzten zuges einer schachpartie den
untergang bedeuten könnte wie jenes
hongkong das wir kennen und dass die
mehrheit der hongkonger als ihre heimat
als einer insel der freiheit inmitten
der totalität und autokratie liebt und
jetzt passt bitte mal gut auf
eine zukunft in chinesischen händen
meine lieben freunde von virtual politik
wenn das geschäft eines unternehmens den
bach runtergeht sind davon nicht nur die
aktionäre betroffen sondern vor allem
auch die mitarbeiter welche als erste
wahrscheinlich die folgen zu spüren
bekommen
nach dem ausbruch der cholera epidemie
sah sich gezwungen 90 prozent seiner
flüge aus chinesische festland und 30
prozent aller flüge weltweit auszusetzen
daraufhin hat das unternehmen 27.000
mitarbeiter gebeten drei wochen
unbezahlten urlaub zu nehmen um seine
fixkosten zu senken und zu versuchen
diese schwierige situation zu bewältigen
die meisten dieser mitarbeiter sind
natürlich bürger hongkongs des
widerspenstigen freiheitsliebenden
hongkongs dass sich dem kommunistischen
staat pekings schon seit monaten heftig
widersetzt
so und was nach außen super geist sei es
rein durch die korona
quarantänemaßnahmen verursacht ist in
wahrheit die folge einer kapitän
strafaktion der kommunistischen partei
chinas den chinesischen spitzeln ist ist
nämlich gelungen viele mitarbeiter von
cathay pacific als teilnehmer an
regierungskritischen demonstrationen zu
identifizieren
[Musik]
daraufhin wurde die fluggesellschaft von
peking unter druck gesetzt diese
mitarbeiter selbst zu disziplinieren als
ich kenne jedoch weigerte entschied man
sich unter dem deckmantel der kroner
sicherheitsmaßnahmen die daumenschrauben
fester anzuziehen
wie aber sollte es eigentlich gehen es
heißt doch immer ein last zwei systeme
cathay pacific hat ihren sitz noch
immerhin einigermaßen demokratischen
hongkong und muss doch die bürgerrechte
ihrer mitarbeiter respektieren und dazu
gehört nun mal das demokratische
grundrecht ein arbeitgeber kann in einem
freiheitlichen staat seine mitarbeiter
doch nicht einfach für die ausübung
ihrer bürgerrechte bestrafen und peking
kann doch nicht einfach ceesay
mitarbeiter in hongkong abstrafen oder
nein aber peking hat andere druckmittel
zum beispiel die vergabe bzw den entzug
von lande und flugrechten auf dem
chinesischen festland
die beiden höchsten cash chefs robert
hock und johns los hatten sich vor ihre
mitarbeiter gestellt und deren
demokratisches demonstrationsrecht
verteidigt doch dann wurde der druck der
chinesischen regierung die kompromisslos
verlangte dass die fluggesellschaft ihre
mitarbeiter unter kontrolle bringt so
groß dass beide ihr amt aufgeben mussten
die neuen bosse fressen peking nun aus
der hand die fluggesellschaft führte
eine unnachgiebige politik gegen all
jene mitarbeiter ein die an den
protesten teilnehmen oder sie sogar über
soziale netzwerke unterstützen
mindestens zwei dutzend mitarbeiter
wurden fristlos entlassen
genau china zwingt ein hongkonger
unternehmen dazu das politische
engagement seiner mitarbeiter zu
kontrollieren das klingt verrückt und
skrupellos aber wie man sieht nicht für
das kommunistische regime chinas das
aber ist noch nicht das ende der
veranstaltung denn die kp chinas kennt
wahrlich keine hemmungen wenn es darum
geht die totale macht in hongkong zu
erlangen und als die korona epidemie auf
kam er könnte sie blitzschnell wie sie
diese für ihre eigenen zwecke
missbrauchen kann
[Musik]
die finanziellen probleme bei cathay
pacific aufgrund der protest in hongkong
und der quarantänemaßnahmen könnten für
china zu einer einmaligen gelegenheit
werden die kontrolle über hongkongs
wichtigste airline ein für alle mal zu
übernehmen seit mehr als zehn jahren
hält china staatliche fluggesellschaft
air china bereits 30 prozent an cathay
pacific nach der hongkonger
unternehmensgruppe firepass effekt die
45 prozent aktien kontrolliert ist sie
damit der zweitgrößte aktionär nun muss
peking den konzern einfach nur so lange
im würgegriff halten bis das unternehmen
zu einer kapitalerhöhung gezwungen ist
um nicht pleitezugehen dann kann die
chinesische regierung ihre bedingungen
für eine gnädige kapitalspritze
diktieren und diese mit der übernahme
der aktienmehrheit verbinden mit der
übernahme der macht in wichtigsten
unternehmen hongkongs würde pekings
kontrolle über das leben der menschen in
der metropole und ihre zukunft noch
größer werden
[Musik]
jetzt wissen wir also dass die regierung
sich in pinks jede erdenkliche situation
ausnutzen weise selbst eine so
schreckliche wie die durch das corona
virus verursachte was wohnung betrifft
so scheint es jedenfalls dass peking ist
mit dem zitat des tschechischen
schriftstellers pavel kostal erhält
kommunisten wissen immer sehr gut wie
man den nagel auf den kopf trifft
und was wir auf gar keinen fall
vergessen dürfen ist die tatsache dass
cathay pacific nur eines von vielen
beispielen ist es ist nichts anderes als
ein spiegelbild all dessen was gerade
mit hongkong geschieht einer stadt die
gesellschaftlich in flammen steht und
jeden tag näher daran scheint vom
chinesischen moloch verschlungen zu
werden
so und jetzt seid ihr an der reihe was
man dir werden die pläne pekings
aufgehen habt ihr noch weitere beispiele
für die rigorose expansionspolitik der
chinesischen kp wie könnten die menschen
in hongkong deren machenschaften doch
noch durchkreuzen kann der
machtmissbrauch im rahmen der maßnahmen
gegen des corona virus vielleicht doch
ein risiko shipping darstellen oder geht
die kp aus dieser krise mit
unvergleichlich gestärkter macht und
noch mehr totalitärer kontrolle über die
menschen chinas und hongkongs heraus und
was denkt ihr über den einfluss klick
ist in vielen anderen ländern in afrika
wenn es wäre ja auch deutschland kommen
hier ähnliche methoden zum einsatz zum
beispiel bei geschäftsbeziehungen und
investitionen und wie sieht es in
anderen ländern aus gibt es auch in
anderen vielleicht sogar demokratischen
ländern mitnahmeeffekte durch die korona
krise wie immer freuen uns auf eure
schaffen und hochgradig querulatorischen
kommentare und wisst ihr dass wir jede
woche neue informative videos für euch
vorbereitung veröffentlichen wenn ihr
also kann es diese aktuelle updates
verpassen wollt abonniert bitte visual
politik und drückt danach auch auf die
taste wenn er dieses video interessant
fanden dann gibt uns auch ein like bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]